what's up reject nation i'm greg outlet
I'm John Humphrey d23 expo in Anaheim is
going on right now we're waiting for
stuff to drop weight for that
mandalorian trailer to come out at some
point and then whatever else are heard
there might be a lady in the [ __ ]
trailer expected to debut your best bet
that we'll be covering it as of today I
think as of today figured in the
meantime let's talk about something
Disney Plus oh good apparently they've
unveiled some posters for their Disney
Plus shows and I thought it'd be fun to
take a look at them do a poster react
sometimes people are like oh sure comes
out like I wanna do a video about just
one poster but apparently there's
several oh good let's let's go into it
alright which one first job Mandalorian
or lady in the [ __ ] those are the two
big ones
let's start with the Mandalorian cuz I
feel like there's less gonna be
surprised yes
Wow Logan and terminators are yeah I
like this template it's a well worn
template and you know it fits into the
vibe that they're going for with the
Mandalorian Western spaghetti store the
thing I like it no yeah I think you get
a lot of the really cool vibes from it
now like you said western spaghetti
Flair that they're talking about the the
lone warrior vibe you can see a ship in
the background called a raise request I
don't know where I g88 is why aren't we
focusing more on IG 8 where's tyga
where's ty cos character yeah man but I
think that looks really cool man
any cool poster yeah I mean it
definitely makes me think of that theme
from started yeah that like sad theme
that they play sometimes in the desert
II scene I like the text that they have
a lot forward to of worse as the
Mandalorian yeah I like how yeah like
how you got to this is a Mandalorian
it's the sunset in the background in it
let's put it right there in the a as
well you can see the photoshopping
you're like okay so you took the horizon
and transposed it and probably stretched
it a little on to this word and then you
took your little man here you little
Mandalorian man and it's the same exact
photo yeah spatially except to me it
looks like his head is slightly turned
to the right Oh any of Star Wars fan
that agrees to come at it what is he
looking at it could be anything but now
I'm excited for this show I'm eagerly
anticipating the trailer for that all
right let's look at the next big one
Lady and the [ __ ] I've been actually
really wondering what about this whole
thing I don't I heard that the dog who
plays a [ __ ] is oh man he was total
diva yeah no it's it's a rescue dog
apparently Oh tell you what man let's
pull you out of here let's give you a
job let's get you to work Hey
homeless man comes star in our Disney
film I'm really wondering how this one's
gonna go down because they got real dogs
they obviously see she hides some of
them for their eyes and the expressions
and stuff they do look sad he's a Lion
King syndrome yeah you can't really make
their faces move too much but dot but
dogs a Moute
don't know what dogs are smiling and
stuff dogs do a moan I think they've
given them both you know at least the
mouth curvature of a smile but there's
something about those like big dog eyes
I think that communicates a certain
sense of longing sadness or some kind of
like do you still love me yeah they're
both giving each other the Ryan Gosling
stare right now staring directly looks
like they're doing one of their acting
class exercises when they got these dogs
ready learn make eye contact feel each
other out yeah very very curious to see
footage wonder if they'll have these
dogs walk the red carpet oh they'll be
the 105 d23 right now throwing treats up
at the states okay now what else do we
got here we
you think all know well what is this
saving Christmas together oh joy no it
looks like they're gonna have to take on
the role of Santa Claus in some way or
another I've never even heard of this I
know but it's got Anna Kendrick and Bill
Hader so it's got to be you know
appealing that of everything they've
announced first I don't I have no
footage to go off of but this poster
this looks the most like made-for-tv sec
family like special christmas movie
they've done which I'm sure will be a
big kid I'm a sucker for those kinds of
little Christmas movies that are so
cheesy and corny but come on it yes
they're both very talented though and
Bill Hader even now totally unrelated
what kind of it chapter two the big
scene stealer that everyone's raving
about isn't yeah it can't it can't yeah
if she shows that makes a cameo and
steals the whole show yeah I feel like
it'll be one of those hallmark movies
but instead of you know like a
Hasselhoff or Andie MacDowell will get
you know super stars whoa we're on
Disney Plus is Twitter right now see the
world through his eyes the world
according to Jeff Goldblum this is news
to me and I'm so this is a great idea
what do tattoos bicycles barbeque gaming
jewelry Cosme medics sneakers caught ice
cream look out Jerry
what the hell is this show I don't know
what is Jeff Goldblum
stream-of-consciousness I want to see
the world for a streaming service basis
this seems like the most internet-based
show you can do right here yeah this
seems like a perfect streamer might one
of my favorite I listen to Conan
O'Brien's a friend the podcast and one
of the best ones is yeah that's a
beautiful right there oh I've seen all
of these movies oh this is by far the
most exciting yeah we got a high school
musical The Musical this series Wow oh
what a terrible Thomas this poster is
hurting my teeth a little bit almost all
in this together that's fine the
taglines fine and that girl in the
middle looks like
like a h down version of an actress I
saw in a Disney movie like ten years ago
so that's freaking me out but yeah this
is a weird post yeah well looks like
they're trying to cover all kinds of
markets here you got only looks like the
Trent transition everything that has
been Disney produced on television yeah
- this is Disney flusher you got your
ABC Family Christmas movie you got your
Disney Channel movie regional show oh
that's a difference - it's a series as
opposed to a movie his high school movie
musicals were movies look out Glee a
high school that's just a terrible title
high school musical the musical the
series why not just call high school
musical the series that's yeah the dead
know that's gonna be a hashtag train
wreck waiting that's so dumb yeah why
would you bother calling it the musical
we get it we got it we've gotten it for
years Oh Bolton we understand at least
we know about High School Musical yeah I
have yeah I really want to know what
they were thinking with that are they
playing the kids Zac Efron and Vanessa
Hudgens do they think that by going high
school musical this series people will
go where no music it's another musical
instead of Corbin Bleu they got this
girl mm-hmm awesome yeah it's gonna be
great it's gonna be yeah they're all the
descendants of the original high
schoolers and then you know occasionally
they'll come back for like a PTA episode
this is the weirdest variety
announcement I see then you got your
weird stream of conscious thing I think
to peel - that's not gonna feel the kids
or families the world according to Jeff
go blue I think it appeals to all of us
in the middle who are just like Jeff
Goldblum anything Jeff Gould yes okay
then you guys your romantic comedy with
adults but weirdly the no well one might
be able to entice more than enough
people with the idea that you have two
actors who are really drawn to adult
audiences especially Bill Hader yeah and
you know Anna Kendrick it's a safe bet
they always some I have a friend who's
always giving me that advice if you're
in the movie biz always do something
Christmas cuz that's the gift that keeps
on giving this is great this is the most
citing theme to currently come out of
d23 at this moment I heard a mean ah
when is gonna be she's being honored and
she's gonna be in the Mandalorian show
alright yeah I don't know if it's like a
series regular just like an episode
characters a shield yeah Avengers campus
you were seeing some footage from that
so there is more news expected to come
out but while we're filming let's just
make sure that there's nothing else that
has currently dropped in the meantime it
looks like Sony Studios is burning to
the ground Oh interesting
no those people cosplaying right now
have been like someone's dressed up as
spider-man I saw a photo going around I
was saying I belong with Marvel not Sony
no they have to address it tomorrow
because like Marvel like the movies and
stuff are being talked about on Saturday
so they have to address it a half URLs
somebody's gonna get on the mic and be
like so what what what would happen with
all the spider-man business they usually
moderate the questions okay ask don't
ask mother I did see a Robert Downey jr.
and Tom Holland posing together and I
heard Tom Holland unfollowed Sony but
then on Jim Pascal tweeting him not I
can't talk about this move for unfolded
yeah what can I do to that it doesn't
break my contract but show that I'm
upset and then in the future contracts
will be like you can't unfollow us for
five years all right guys well keep a
lookout for when we'll cover like actual
footage that they release online if it's
anything leaked not gonna cover it cuz I
don't want to get in trouble let those
other people who are uploading it intro
well to keep up with us you can
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification about seeing you notify
when we have a new video up catch you
guys soon